[Music]
i thought i would start right in your
wheelhouse and use a headline to
introduce
the subject of vision scientific
american interviewed you not long ago
and they titled the piece quote vision
and breathing may be the secrets to
surviving 2020 end quote
so breathing i think for a lot of folks
might seem self-evident stop that you
have a lot of problems on your hands or
if you do it incorrectly we can we can
certainly dive into that later on vision
i think will jump out is perhaps odd to
a lot of folks
why vision why is vision
perhaps a secret or a key to surviving
2020 or any year for that matter
yeah so the vision and our visual system
is perhaps the strongest
lever by which we can shift our state of
mind and body
and that might at first come as a
surprise because we think of vision as
this
thing that we have to see colors and
motion and recognize faces etc but the
two little goodies in the front of our
skull our eyes
are actually part of our central nervous
system so a lot of people don't realize
this but your neural retina the little
light sensing piece of the eyes in the
back of the eye kind of lines it like a
pie crust
or actually two pieces of your brain
that were deliberately
squeezed out during early development so
they're the only two pieces of your
brain that are outside the cranial vault
as we say
and those little pieces of brain
have an enormous impact on the state of
the rest of your brain so it's fair to
say that what you see and how you view
the world literally
has an incredible impact on your state
of mind respiration breathing also on
your state of mind and body but the
reason is the following
our visual system is not just for
seeing objects shapes and colors etc
our eyes have two functions so much in
the same way that our ears are
responsible for hearing but also there's
a balance mechanism in there our eyes
are responsible for detecting shapes and
colors etc but also for telling the rest
of the brain
whether or not to be more alert or more
relaxed and the most fundamental way
that our eyes do that is communicating
time of day the presence or absence of
sunlight to our central circadian clock
and then the central circadian clock
which is really just an aggregation of
neurons communicates to the rest of the
brain and body whether or not for
instance metabolism should be higher
metabolism should be low whether or not
we should feel like moving or feel like
lying down and not moving at all but
there are a number of ways in which the
visual system works on fast time scales
to adjust our inner state
and one of the most simple ways that it
does that
is one that normally happens when we're
stressed or relaxed but we don't
recognize it so for instance if we are
very relaxed
our pupils change or the shape of our
lens changes such that we actually have
dilated vision we see the entire
environment we're in so-called panoramic
vision
when we are stressed or we are excited
about something the pupils dilate the
shape of our lens changes literally the
optics of our eye changes and the
information about the outside world
that's delivered to our the rest of our
brain and body changes the aperture of
our experience our entire experience
shrinks we get so-called soda straw view
of the world we're looking through soda
straws essentially when we are alert or
stressed
and
we've experienced this but we don't
normally notice it happening so much
like breathing our experience of life
whether or not we're alert or stressed
excited or calm changes our patterns of
breathing we're all accustomed to that
you know our breathing's speeding up
we're holding our breath in anticipation
but as well our inner state drives
changes in our visual system the
aperture of whether or not we see the
big picture or we have a very contracted
view of the world but both those things
breathing and vision also run in reverse
meaning if we change our pattern of
breathing we change our inner state
if our state changes our breathing
changes so it's reciprocal it's
bi-directional likewise with vision when
we are excited or stressed the aperture
of our visual window shrinks we get that
soda straw view of the world when we are
relaxed the aperture of our vision
expands
but as well it runs in both directions
if we expand our view of the world
literally force our our visual field or
just it's very easy actually you can do
it no matter where you are right now if
you just try and expand your visual
field not by looking around or moving
your head or eyes but by
trying to see yourself in the
environment that you're in so you
literally dilate your view so you could
see the ceiling and the floor and the
walls if you're inside or if you're
outdoors seeing as big an aperture of
your visual field or your visual
environment is possible so you're
directing your attention to even though
you might remain looking straight ahead
you're just directing your attention to
as wide a peripheral view horizontally
and vertically as possible is that what
you mean that's right exactly so
essentially if you keep your head and
eyes mostly stationary you don't have to
be you know rigid about rock steady but
if you look forward and you expand your
field of view so you kind of relax your
eyes so that you can see as much of your
environment around you as possible to
the point where you can see yourself in
that environment what you do is you are
turning off the attentional and believe
it or not the stress mechanisms that
drive your internal state towards stress
this is why when you go to a
vista or you view a horizon it's very
relaxing because you naturally go into
panoramic vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at a computer
or a camera or something of that sort or
you're talking to somebody or an intense
conversation you may not notice it but
your entire visual field shrinks to a
much smaller aperture and that drives an
increase in alertness in internal state
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience if it's a
positive experience we might call that
love or obsession or fascination but
the important thing to realize is that
both vision and breathing
have a profound and very rapid effect on
our internal state of mind and body and
it runs in both directions
our internal state that could be
triggered by a text message or hearing
something that somebody says drives
changes in our breathing and our vision
but our breathing and our vision can
also drive changes in our internal state
and so that article in scientific
american was a discussion about how we
can
leverage the visual system and the
respiration the breathing system in
order to take control over our internal
state because
it's not just that 2020 was stressful
it's that our internal state determines
everything it doesn't just determine if
we feel
like we're having a hard time falling
asleep or we're having a hard time
focusing for instance it also determines
how we batch time how we analyze
where we are in the world in terms of
our lifespan a good example this would
be when we are very stressed we find
slice time this is why when people are
in a car accident or something they
might report that things were in slow
motion they're actually your frame rate
increases whereas when you're very
relaxed your frame rate slows down and
when we are relaxed we get so-called
perspective
we are able to say well this too shall
pass or i can place the stressful event
in a context so one thing that's just
fundamental to our nervous system works
is that we are constantly placing our
experience both our immediate and past
experience as well as our anticipation
of the future into some sort of larger
context and our visual system literally
how we are viewing the world at that
moment dictates how we create
perspective in terms of states of mind
sounds a little bit abstract but it's
actually it boils right down to optics
of the eye and very concrete things like
how you move your eyes and how you view
the world
you